Renee Dixon lives in Indianapolis,
and has worked in early childhood education for 25 years.
And today she works as a preschool director.
But what makes her so special
is that she has spent every weekend
for the last four years driving for Uber
in order to buy supplies, gifts, clothes for her students.
I'm so excited to talk to her.
Renee, are you there?
I am, how are you?
(audience claps)
It's so nice to meet you.
I have been so looking forward to meeting you.
So how did you first become passionate about education?
Like was there a moment in your life?
Was it over time?
What was it?
It was, I'm from Mississippi, so I used to work
at the Mississippi State Penitentiary men death row.
And I start seeing younger
and younger people come into the system.
And I said, something's wrong.
Somewhere someone missed something.
So when I moved to Indianapolis, I said,
I need to be there, I have to be there.
This is my calling, to be there for kids.
And you think that's maybe like the missing link,
as far as if there is love, consistency,
availability, resources, that that will have
a trickle-down effect or matriculate,
as they say in your world, into young adults?
Yes, I mean, in the first five years
of a child's life is the most important five years.
And they learn so much,
their little brains are like sponges.
And every little thing that you do,
and every little science experiment
that you do with them, it's amazing.
Even just put a vinegar with baking soda,
they're like, oh my God, how did you do that?
Is that magic? (laughs)
That's literally my daughter in a nutshell.
Every day, all around the house.
I call her the alchemist anarchist.
(audience laughs)
What gave you the idea, then, to start driving
for Uber on weekends to raise money?
Well, I worked for a company.
They didn't really have a budget for the classroom.
And my students needed everything.
And I said, I have to be there, I have to be that person.
So at least taking some of the load off the parents.
So I started doing that.
And then Christmas came, and I bought Christmas presents.
But this last year, it was harder because COVID.
And a lot of my families who are living
below the poverty line,
they told me they can't afford presents for their kids.
And I'm like, no child should ever wake up
not have a Christmas present,
because I've been there before.
Growing up, my mom was a single mom.
And I said, no, your child's gonna have
a Christmas and a Christmas present.
And I said, and then if you have children,
other children, they are gonna have it.
So I have 50 students and 20 siblings, so 70 kids.
I mean, it was a lot of work.
But if I didn't do it, then who else?
Because a lot of parents were used
to being that giving person.
And now they have to be the person that received the help.
And they were kind of embarrassed about it.
I'm like, there's nothing to be embarrassed about.
Everybody's gonna go through something once in their life.
I'm here, I got it.
I told them I got it, I got it.
I'ma do it, I'm gonna do it.
There are nights I'm like, you ain't gonna do it.
I'm like, I'm gonna do it, I'm gonna do it, I'm gonna do it.
I mean, when I work seven to six Monday through Fridays.
And on Fridays, when I get off at six o'clock,
I gas my car up, work until one, two o'clock in the morning,
take a little nap, get up at eight, sometimes nine,
drive till one, two o'clock Sunday morning,
take a little nap, get up eight, nine o'clock,
and drive till four o'clock on Sundays.
And then after the four, I sleep. (laughs)
I have so many thoughts and feelings right now.
A, I wanna be your best friend.
B, I want everyone to be like you.
C, I'm just so glad that you're in the world,
that you grew up with a single mom,
that you worked on death row.
You saw a discrepancy, you went
and you studied and got your degree in psychology
and early child education, became a teacher.
Take care of the students, provide them with shoes,
clothes, shelter, like love, a good attitude,
and then go and help their parents
and drive all weekend to fund it.
I just had to do a recap because it's just so incredible.
(audience claps)
I mean, it's something that I have to do.
(audience cheers)
Oh, thank you.
It's something I have to do.
I just wanna say, I thank you for going above and beyond.
And BP wants to give you this $5,000 gift card
that can be used at BP and AMOCO stations.
(audience claps)
And then we wanted to get something else for your kids.
So today Kidpik, the number one clothing subscription box
for kids, wants to donate another $5,000 worth
of winter clothing for you and your students.
I haven't done anything special.
(audience claps)
You know what, Renee?
I don't think any of us are gonna even come close
to measuring up to what you do.
So I mean, you're a teacher for a reason.
'Cause you're teaching a lot more than your students.
Thank you guys so much.
I mean, do you really think that what you do
is like the bare minimum and not special?
That's what you're supposed to do.
This is what you're supposed to do.
I was always taught, this is what you supposed to do.
Who taught you that, may I ask?
My mom and my aunt and my grandmother.
They always said, this is what you're supposed to do.
I just want everyone to be like you.
And you are our teacher, Renee.
I can't thank you enough.
Thank you.
(audience cheers)
And your mom and your aunt,
and all your students and their family.
We just send so much love and gratitude to everyone.
And thank you to BP and Kidpik.
Thank you so much to these companies.
Thank you.
And Renee, we'll be in touch.
(upbeat music)